but a court in Russia has rejected an
appeal by Wall Street Journal reporter
Ivan gershkovic against his continued
detention on spying charges the 31 year
old U.S citizen was arrested in March
while on a reporting trip gershkevich on
the Wall Street Journal have denied he
spied in Russia the U.S says he was
wrongfully detained and is demanding his
immediate release
joins us live now from Moscow so you
look what more are you hearing from the
courtroom
so the hearing has already finished but
it did attract great a great portion of
international attention carry we even
saw the arrival of the U.S ambassador to
Russia at the Moscow city court so as
you said the court extended the arrest
of Evan gershkovich till the end of
August his parents were allowed into the
courtroom to support him and they
managed to talk with their son during a
break gashkovich is facing Espionage
charges meaning he can receive up to 20
years in jail he was attained in the
city of yaketerenberg and Russia's Euros
at the end of March and later he was
transferred to Moscow the FSB claims
that he was collecting secret
information about one of the military
Industrial Enterprises there and also
according to the Kremlin spokesman
gershkovic was called red-handed but
taking into account that he was arrested
while leaving a restaurant that
statement raises eyebrows really
according to Evan's friends there in
yigatierenberg he was gathering material
for an article about what people the
urals think about Russia's invasion of
Ukraine actually all people here who
have ever met him in person say that
what a nice guy he is his parents are
USSR immigration the U.S and Evan
himself is a huge fan of Russia plus his
Russian is impeccable the U.S
authorities as well as Urban himself
consider the accusations of baseless
there was also a letter signed by modern
theater world media Outlets to the
Russian ambassador to the U.S demanding
the release of gershkovich but probably
things will slightly change in a
positive way forever now as right before
today's hearing there was a statement by
Russia's Deputy foreign minister Sergey
abkov and according to him the U.S
request for Consular access to
gershkovic has been received by the
Russian side and is now being considered
and as of now Evan will remain in the
Detention Center here in Moscow for
three more months
alive for us there from Moscow thank you